momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo América edición nocturna me
acompañan el estudio Jorge Hurtado Jorge
muy buenas noches en esta edición
analizaremos ese creciente flujo de
remesas hacia los países
latinoamericanos y el impacto que tienen
a nivel social principalmente en México
Santiago y es que a propósito de que
esta semana las remesas en México
tocaron un récord histórico de
58,497 millones de dólares en 2022 la
recepción de dinero proveniente de
extranjeros se ha convertido en uno de
los principales salvavidas de las
familias mexicanas y también
latinoamericanas en un entorno económico
complejo tras la crisis que dejó la
pandemia en México las remesas superan
ahora casi todas las fuentes de ingreso
exteriores de ese país incluido el
turismo las exportaciones de petróleo y
la mayoría de las exportaciones
manufactureras Incluso si se analizan
las remesas a nivel global América
Latina impulsa el crecimiento de envío
de remesas parte importante la lleva por
supuesto México que es el segundo mayor
sector del mundo esa tendencia
continuará en 2023 según los analistas
aunque aún menos ritmo esto por las
condiciones económicas de Estados Unidos
que tiene una influencia enorme en el
envío de remesas en Centroamérica y el
Caribe se estima que las remesas América
Latina y el Caribe aumentaron un nueve
coma tres por ciento en 2022 hasta los
142 mil millones de dólares los datos
correspondientes por ejemplo a los
primeros nueve meses del 2022 indican Un
aumento del envío de remesas del 45%
para Nicaragua un 20% para Guatemala un
15% para México y un 9% para Colombia y
cuál es el impacto que tienen estas
remesas en las economías de estos países
latinoamericanos Jorge Bueno las remesas
constituyen parte importante del
producto interno bruto en varios países
de Centroamérica y el Caribe esto porque
alivia en la pobreza también mejoran los
resultados nutricionales y están
asociadas a un mayor peso al nacer y
tasas de escolaridad elevada entre los
niños de hogares desfavorecidos los
estudios indican que las remesas ayudan
a los hogares receptores a fortalecer su
resiliencia un ejemplo de ello Es cuando
ayudan a una familia a obtener el
financiamiento de una vivienda más
adecuada y les permite afrontar perdidas
después de una crisis pero las remesas
pueden ser un arma de doble filo para
las economías así lo explica marco
Aurelio Peña economista abogado y
especialista en desarrollo económico
una faceta positiva lo que podemos
destacar como faceta positiva es que las
familias las personas por cooperación
espontánea por su propia iniciativa por
su afán de sobrevivencia no se quedan de
brazos cruzados sino que toman sus
propias decisiones microeconómicas para
irse verdad Y luego ubicarse en un
mercado de trabajo Mucho más grande
mucho más brillante mucho más Dinámico
este en donde van a ganar muchísimo más
dinero para luego una fracción de su
ingreso personal
enviárselo mediante un espíritu de
solidaridad a su familia en su país de
origen y con esto sostener determinado
nivel de consumo individual familiar Y
por supuesto ayudar a equilibrar la
balanza de pago de estos países México
es el gran receptor de remesas monetaria
a nivel latinoamericano Guatemala es el
gran receptor de remesas monetarias a
nivel centroamericano y en el y es lo
mismo también para El Salvador y
Nicaragua que por cierto este año eh Qué
pasó superó los tres mil millones de
dólares Entonces por esa parte hay una
fácil una faceta positiva de la gente
saliendo adelante por su propio esfuerzo
y por su propia iniciativa asumiendo su
propio récord y tomando decisiones en
condiciones de incertidumbre y peligro y
por otro lado la faceta negativa es que
los mercados internos particularmente
los mercados de trabajo no logran
retener este talento humano esta fuerza
de trabajo sino que este excedente se va
el país no es capaz de a través de una
estrategia de crecimiento y desarrollo
económico retener a su talento humano y
a su fuerza de trabajo Santiago y un
ejemplo de ello en un estudio del Banco
Mundial revela como las remesas han
superado por mucho a la inversión
extranjera directa y también a la ayuda
oficial al desarrollo en países de
América Latina y el Caribe otro estudio
realizado en 71 países de ingreso bajo
revelan también que cada incremento del
10% en el volumen de remesas se traduce
en una disminución del 3,5% En los
niveles de pobreza y en contextos
económicos difíciles como los actuales
los envíos de dinero sin duda son
fundamentales Muchas gracias Jorge por
toda esta explicación y el contexto que
envuelve el tema de las remesas para
América Latina Gracias por esta
actualización y a continuación una
semana en el mundo siga con nosotros